the point of this video is to try and
figure out
all of the different threats to humanity
that exist
now before the pandemic there are lots
of people warning us that something like
this would happen at some stage and yet
when it happened
we as a society were completely
unprepared for it
now this made me wonder what other
things exist out there
other disasters that could happen that
we're not prepared for so
i collected them all together and put
them in this this is the map of doom
crikey there's quite a lot aren't there
but just finding all of these disaster
scenarios isn't enough i also wanted to
figure out which ones pose the biggest
threat to humanity using some real data
and i think i've hit on a really nice
way of visualizing the relative threats
of all of these different disasters in
this doom chart
so by the end of this video you should
have a good idea of what the biggest
threats to humanity
are and so which ones we should be
focusing most of our energy on trying to
mitigate and prevent
[Music]
so here's everything that might befall
us as a human race
all of the calamities i could find
there's a bunch of stuff from space like
asteroid impacts
natural disasters earthquakes volcanoes
and
a bunch of stuff waiting to ourselves
war climate change
and a few futuristic scenarios like robo
apocalypses now let me show you how i'm
going to compare
all of these things so you can break
down the risk of a disaster into two
parts first of all
are the potential number of casualties
it would cause if it happened
so the total number of deaths it would
cause and then the second is the
likelihood of that event happening
so for example an asteroid impact could
cause a huge number of casualties but
it's very unlikely so every disaster on
this map is going to have some
combination of
of these two numbers so what we can do
is actually plot all the disasters
on a scatter plot on the horizontal axis
we're going to plot
the casualties which go from a thousand
deaths all the way up to eight billion
deaths which is
basically more than the total population
of humanity so
we've got a zone of total extinction on
the left-hand side which will capture
all the existential threats to humanity
and this is a log plot so each tick here
is 10 times as many casualties
as the last one then on the vertical
axis
we've got the likelihood of an event
happening so the most
likely events are at the top so this
would be an event that happens
on average once per year again on a log
plot we go all the way down
to an event that happens on average once
every billion years
but typically events down at that end
it's very hard to assess the likelihood
of those events in fact at the very
bottom i'm going to put a bin for things
that is impossible to determine the
likelihood for
things that have never happened before
like a robo apocalypse like how do we
assess the likelihood that that's going
to happen
it's good to think about but yeah you
can't
draw on any past data um
the terminator movers don't count and
then at the very top we've got the most
likely events in fact
we've got a bin for the things that are
actually happening right now
already so things like earthquakes
happen every single year
and so those cause a certain number of
casualties in fact
let's look at the very first one
earthquakes
the magnitude 8 earthquake hits
somewhere on earth on average once
per year and around 10 000 people die
per year because of earthquakes and the
resulting effects things like tsunamis
or mudslides
so we can put a point on our scatter
plot
in the already happening zone to
represent this
but if we look at the history of
earthquakes there are more severe
earthquakes that kill more people the
most destructive earthquake was
in 16th century china killed around 830
000 people in one event
and also over the last 100 years we've
had about a million deaths due to
earthquakes and so we can extend this
out into a line which captures
the the general risk over a certain time
scale of earthquakes
as this is based on real data what it's
telling us is that this is the expected
lives lost
due to earthquakes over these time
scales unfortunately this line doesn't
extend any further because
earthquakes are relatively localized and
so they don't pose a risk to the entire
human population
and so now as we add more disasters to
this doom chart we can assess
how scary they are relative to
earthquakes
so anything further up is more likely
and anything
further to the right is more deathy and
so those are the things we really want
to worry about in fact
why don't we label these different
quadrants
on the lower left we've got the low
likelihood and low casualty events
these i'm going to call the freak
accidents things like personally being
hit by an asteroid
or being killed by a shark attack or
being one of the eight unfortunate
people to die
from the london beer flood of 1814
on the top left we've got the really bad
events things that are relatively likely
but have
relatively low casualty rate where
relative means
relative to the entire extinction of the
human race
um on the bottom right we've got total
disasters but
unlikely things like asteroid impacts
and on the top right we've got the just
straight up total disasters
things that will be very likely and also
cause huge amounts of casualties so we
really want to be
worried about anything that falls into
that top right quadrant
let's look at asteroid impacts next
because we've got some really good data
on the likelihood of an impact based on
past
impacts and looking at the moon and also
the size distribution of
near-earth objects from sky surveys
small asteroids
hit the earth all the time and large
asteroids
hit less frequently the larger that they
get but the risk to humans kicks in
for diameters of the asteroids around
140 meters and larger
the one that killed off the dinosaurs
was around 10 kilometers in diameter
and in this range we can have big
calamities things like
giant tsunamis caused by the asteroid
crashing into the ocean
or the real killer is the amount of dust
that's kicked
kicked up by an asteroid impact it would
cover the globe for many years
obscuring the sun instigating a mini ice
age cooling global temperatures
we wouldn't be able to go grow crops so
we'd have crop failures around the world
not enough food
global famine possibly war
to fight for resources and the possible
extinction
of the human race the smaller 140 meter
asteroids will collide with the earth
roughly once every 30
000 years and the larger ten kilometer
asteroids would hit
roughly once every hundred million years
and the estimate of deaths goes from
around three million for the smaller
asteroids up to
total extinction for the ten kilometer
asteroids
fortunately we can actively try and
detect and prevent asteroid impacts by
doing good astrophysics
and in fact derek on his channel
veritasium has done a companion video to
this one where he delves deeper into
asteroids and asteroid impact so after
you've watched this video i highly
recommend you go check that out
the links in the description below okay
now let's move on to look at
super volcanoes giant volcanic eruptions
that happen on earth around once every
hundred thousand years
these kick up huge amounts of smoke and
dust and the scenario is very similar to
asteroid impacts
where they obscure the sun for many
years leading to the failure of food
crops
and global mass famine and death
the last super volcano eruption was in
indonesia mount toba which happened 74
000 years ago and led to
global cooling of temperatures around
three to five
celsius which led to a huge loss of
plant and animal life and some people
think it actually
brought our species close to extinction
when it happens
and worryingly there's actually nothing
we can do to prevent a super volcano
eruption
the only thing we could do is to make
our food systems more resilient
to these big disasters which seems like
a sensible thing to do
if that seems depressing because this
video was brought to you by existential
dread
and if you want your own slice you too
can own the map of doom
perfect for any home socially distanced
workplace
or nuclear bunker the map of doom will
take your mind off the pandemic when you
realize how many other things you should
be worrying about
grab your map of doom now from dftba.com
domain of science and the first 200
poster sales will also get this cool
sticker also available separately as a
sticker and a pin
fixes central dread should be taken
responsibly may lead you to wonder what
the point of it all
is this is perfectly normal please
remember to vote here is a picture of a
kitten
okay now that we've got a few disasters
on our map let's compare it to our
current pandemic
and pandemics in general covert 19 has
caused over a million deaths
so far we don't quite know how high that
will climb
but for the spanish flu 50 million
people died in 1918.
flu pandemics occur around three times a
century with different levels of
severity
and in general epidemics and pandemic
risk is increasing for example in the
last 20 years we've had
sars mers ebola and the hiv
aids pandemic has claimed 36 million
lives
in between 2005 and 2012.
so pandemics are a very big risk they're
lie around here
and another biological disaster that's
already happening is antibiotic
resistant bacteria which claims around
000 lives per year and this is expected
to climb
up to 10 million lives per year by 2050
unless we find ways of tackling it so
this lies here
this is quite a surprise to me because
this is a bigger risk to us
than pandemics but we don't hear about
it much probably because it's not an
acute event it's just happening in the
background so it doesn't make a good
news story so
this is another thing we're probably not
thinking about enough
and finally to round off the biological
threats we need to think about the risks
posed by
advances in genetic engineering and
synthetic biology
the kovid pandemic has been awful but at
least the death rate's been relatively
low
imagine a pandemic like this but the
death rate's a lot higher
something that's been engineered for
nefarious purposes
either through bioterrorism or
biological warfare or even
a research accident i've got no idea how
to assess
the likelihood of that happening or the
death toll so i'm not putting it on my
doom chart but
something to bear in mind it's
inevitable that video like this is going
to get a little bit heavy so i thought
i'd give us a little break to recoup
because the next section's on the
environment which
as you can imagine isn't the best news
so i'm just doing something that makes
me feel better when i'm staring into the
abyss
having a bit of a sit down and a cup of
tea
let me know in the comments what makes
you feel better when you're
dreading the future sometimes when
things get really bad
i even have a hobnob
it's a bit soft in a way
an environmental disaster would be
similar to an asteroid impact or a super
volcano because the final thing that
would end up killing us is mass
starvation due to
failure of our food production now
there's
a whole complex web of relationships
involved
including climate change and environment
destruction and pollution
which i'm sure you all know by now but
if you want to see the whole network of
relationships pause the video now for an
image put simply we rely on the natural
world to provide food for our massive
population through arable land
fresh water pollinators and also wild
food stocks like fishing
but through climate change and
destruction of the environment and
pollution
we are upsetting the balance of the
natural world
and that's leading to people dying
the best estimate from the world health
organization is that 150
000 people are dying per year due to the
effects of climate change
and this is expected to rise to 250 000
by 2050 and a total of a little bit over
100 million people will have died
because of
causes due to climate change by 2100
and that gives us this line which is
very interesting
when we compare it to the covet pandemic
so this is why people are like
yeah the covert crisis has been really
bad but we shouldn't forget
about climate change this is what
they're talking about because climate
change is basically like a really bad
pandemic
but just spread out and it's actually
worse than this because these numbers
are based on the ipcc projections
and historically the ipcc worst case
scenarios have underperformed actual
data so their worst case scenarios were
actually too
optimistic so what that means is this
line would be
higher up somewhere i don't know how
much higher also i haven't taken into
account things like ecosystem collapse
and pollution
so yeah
now predicting future scenarios is
uncertain because this hasn't happened
yet and a lot of this depends on what
actions we take over the next decade
and beyond but what i wanted to do is in
this context of the doom truck try and
work out a worst case
and best case scenario to at least put
some bounds on it
in the worst cases the question of
whether climate change and environmental
catastrophes
pose an existential threat to the
continued existence of humanity which is
still an
open question we need to take into
account things like climate tipping
points
things like when the arctic permafrost
melts releasing
loads of greenhouse gases into the
atmosphere
or changes in the ocean currents
changing the climate irreversibly
these are like point of no return type
situations which
lead to the very worst outcomes of
climate change
but assessing their likelihoods still
seems to be a contentious issue
but let's say we do nothing and carbon
emissions just keep on rising around the
world
to 150 gigatonnes of carbon by
2100. that would correspond
to around a 15 centigrade rise in
temperatures globally by 2200
and i'm going to say that that is
unlivable for humans in the long term so
i'm going to put that down
as our worst case scenario
now in the best case let's say that the
entire world goes completely carbon
neutral in the next 10 years by 2030
which is which is optimistic but we'll
just go with that
that would mean that we're just locked
into the current death rate due to
climate change
and so we've just got a straight line
here and it just doesn't get any worse
which is interesting when you compare
them like this because climate change
certainly doesn't feel
as acute as this covert pandemic and
the reason is is that climate change
happens every year
and is just spread out over many years
and it's just gradually getting worse
and worse
and for most of us we're not feeling the
direct effects of climate change
yet which leads to the next section
i didn't think that a map of doom would
be complete without things like social
inequality
income inequality or overpopulation but
these aren't
acute disasters that kill a load of
people so why did i include them on the
map well
the reason is is that all of these are
important multiplying effects
for example the covert pandemic was made
worse
by online disinformation and social
inequality
and overpopulation is the major driver
of all of the environmental disasters
like climate change and ecosystem
collapse
one example is that the richest one
percent of the population have emitted
more than double the carbon of the
poorest 50 percent of the population
but climate change is going to hit the
poorest people
the hardest so social inequality makes
disasters worse
so far i've looked at disaster scenarios
where i've got actual data to use for my
doom chart
but from now on it's difficult or
impossible to assess likelihoods
for the following so from now on i'm
just winging it
as is anyone else who talks about these
with that in mind let's crack on total
nuclear war is uh
ever-present threat to humanity it's
hard to predict the likelihood of an
all-out nuclear war for my doom chart
other than it's
on the very high death toll area with 14
000 nuclear warheads continually primed
were a risk of accidents which have very
narrowly missed during the cold war
or things like cyber terrorism they're
continually threatening the entire
existence of humanity
but now we get onto the fun stuff these
last scenarios all share the similar
characteristics of completely destroying
humanity but also being incredibly
low likelihood or being a likelihood we
can't even determine
and also sounding like excellent plots
for a sci-fi movie these include
nanobots or molecular machines gradually
turning
all the material in the world into more
coppers of themselves
the grey goo theory there's also rogue
artificial intelligence in the future
not recognizing the importance of
humans and just gradually wiping us all
out
then in space we've got the uncalculable
risk
of aliens visiting and wanting to kill
us all
or rogue black holes wandering through
our solar system absorbing everything on
its way
or the collapse of the vacuum the idea
that
the whole universe is in a meta-stable
quantum state
and at any time it could find a lower
energy state
and a band of energy would travel at the
speed of light throughout the universe
unraveling everything in its path
then there's the potential for a
gamma-ray burst which is an incredibly
high energy explosion in space
which could wipe out the ozone layer and
expose us to the full ultraviolet
rays of the sun which wouldn't be good
fortunately these are pretty rare
happening once every 10
000 years per galaxy and they're
probably too far away to do
to too much damage there's a potential
that the orbit of mercury is unstable
and could wander out of the solar system
potentially colliding with the earth
although
the likelihood is probably incredibly
small
these are all existential threats to
humanity which certain philosophers have
highlighted because even though the
likelihood of them happening is
incredibly low
the risk that they could wipe out the
whole
of the human race is so severe that
they're things that we should be
spending time
thinking about and trying to avoid
whatever you think about that logic
they're very easy to place on the doom
chart they all
exist down here in the very low
likelihood or impossible to calculate
likelihood in the bottom right corner
apart from
gamma-ray bursts which sit around here
finally we get to the sun bringer of all
life on earth
although one day it will die and so will
we
unless we escape in spaceships
which we've got about a billion years to
figure out before the sun swells
and cooks the earth into an inhospitable
hell hole
so i'm going to put this as a low
probability i mean it's definitely going
to happen but
we've got a billion years and to be
honest if we've survived that long
we'll have done well
so that's my best effort to try and
capture the data i could find
on the relative risks of these different
disaster scenarios
but i'm sure it's not perfect so if you
think i've missed anything
important or if you've got any
constructive feedback on a way
i could improve this please let me know
in the comments below
but this is a cha i'd love the actual
professionals
to produce some visualization like this
for us to be able to compare the
different risks
because i think it'd be a really useful
way of the general public to
see the biggest threats to humanity and
see which of the things we should be
focusing our
energies on trying to prevent all right
well thanks for watching
and make sure you check out derek's
video on asteroid impact on his channel
veritasium
and other than that i'm not going to ask
you to like or subscribe
because you can do what you want so i'll
see you on the next video
she'll be posting in a couple of weeks
[Music]
you